it was a 17-year old high school student
who recorded the video of a Minneapolis
police officer pressing his knee into
George Floyd's neck for 8 minutes and 46
seconds Floyd died after begging for air
we all saw that Darnell affray sure
posted the video on Facebook it led to
protests around the world and a renewed
demand to end police brutality against
black people
Seth cope and his Frazier's attorney he
joins us first on CBS this morning
Seth Cohen thank you so much for joining
us you know Darnell affray sure if it
hadn't been for her video this could
have been a very different story so
people are very grateful to her can you
tell us why she happened to be on the
scene that day what she was doing miss
Frazier was watching her nine-year-old
cousin who asked to go to the store and
being that she was only nine and wasn't
old enough to go by herself my client
brought her there she had no intention
of stumbling upon this historic event so
that means that I've seen it too in fact
that's true
my client was 17 there was a nine year
old present and from what I've heard
there was at least one other teenager
there who watched this event this murder
took place in front of children it's
it's very disturbing to me yeah what
made her start recording Seth well from
what she describes she was about three
storefronts away and she saw these
police officers extracting this
gentleman from his car and doing so
fairly roughly and my client has seen a
lot of police brutality in her
neighborhood there's a lot of violence
directed against her community and she
wanted to document this so when she
reached the scene and she saw this man
on the ground with a police officer
kneeling on his neck she pulled out her
camera and started recording
she knew that without this record these
officers would escape consequences
altogether the world would never know
what had happened that day I don't
believe she had any idea she was gonna
witness a murder she thought this was
just another act of police brutality the
sort of thing that on
fortunately is routine in her
neighborhood it escalated into something
much greater than that it all it also
seems at time officer Chauvin and
officer tao both looked at her dead in
the camera did she feel that too that
they were looking at her she reported
that they were staring directly at her
the entire time
officer tao was shouting at people to
get back on the curb there were a lot of
people on that curb they were shouting
at the officer Chapin to get off this
poor man's neck Tao kept yelling at them
get back on the curb get back on the
curb if he can talk he can breathe they
were staring directly at my client her
cousin and everyone else on that curb
for the entire eight plus minutes that
it took to kill this man
did that frighten her the way they were
looking at her I think she was utterly
terrified she knew that he or she was a
70 year old black woman she was as
vulnerable as anybody at any minute she
could become a victim as well she was
very scared for her life she was very
scared for her safety and her cousin
safety but she knew if she didn't record
this no one would know what had happened
people aren't just gonna believe a
teenager when they she says hey I saw
these cops murder this man people would
not necessarily believe her at all her
word wouldn't carry the weight that a
police officers word carries but this
video carries a great deal of weight
this video is why these officers were
fired this video is why these officers
were charged with murder yeah a lot of
people as I said are very grateful that
there is video now we know by looking at
her videotape that none of the police
officers intervene did she say if any
did any of the bystanders try to
intervene at any point well if you watch
the video you can hear everyone
including my client yelling at the
officers to stop telling chavin to get
off this man's neck in fact there was a
first responder a minute
Minneapolis firefighter I believe who
came upon the scene told the officers
I'm a first responder this man can't
breathe get off his neck you got to get
all get off of him and they told her
like everyone else get back on the curb
stand back get back from the
get back from us hmm and how how is she
doing Seth is she getting any
professional help I I talked to her
grandmother last week who told me that
Darnell is really a very shy girl a good
student and very quiet what is she like
and how is she doing that's a pretty
accurate description of her she's a
really a typical 17 year old she's not a
community leader she's a regular person
who did an extraordinary thing and this
has been very hard on her she's
definitely traumatized she's had trouble
sleeping when she closes her eyes she
sees it all over again this is a really
difficult thing for her to cope with her
entire life has been turned upside down
she went from just another 17 year old
going to high school but working her job
having her friends a boyfriend looking
forward to graduating next year she went
from that to being the center of media
attention the center of the whole
world's attention everything's focused
on her now and it's it's changed her
life in many ways and I don't think
these changes are anything she ever
wanted however she's coping remarkably
well she's a very positive person she is
getting some professional help
thankfully this has been really hard on
her but she knows she did the right
thing and ultimately I think she's going
to turn out all right
oh we all hope so Seth we all hope so
and we certainly thank her Seth thank
you very much for taking the time we
really appreciate it